forgive but do not forget
or you will be hurt again
forgetting loses the lesson
life always waits for some crisis to
occur before revealing itself at its
most brilliant
everyone seems to have a clear idea of
how other people should lead their lives
but none about his or her own
close some doors not because of Pride
incapacity or arrogance
but simply because they no longer lead
somewhere
if you're brave enough to say goodbye
life will reward you with a new hello
haters are confused admirers who can't
understand why everybody else likes you
if you think Adventure is dangerous
dry routine
it is lethal
love is a trap
when it appears we see only its light
not its Shadows
[Music]
few are never alone
you cannot know yourself
we humans have two great problems
the first is knowing when to begin
the second is knowing when to stop
life sometimes separates people so that
they can realize how much they mean to
each other
stake
it is not a mistake anymore
it is a decision
Being Human means having doubts and yet
still continuing on your path
life has a way of testing a person's
will
either by having nothing happen at all
or by having everything happen at once
blessed are those who do not fear
solitude
who are not afraid of their own company
who are not always desperately looking
for something to do
something to amuse themselves with
something to judge
someone leaves it's because someone else
is about to arrive
perfect people don't drink don't lie
don't cheat don't fight
don't complain
and don't exist
every time we repeat the same mistake
price goes up
you will never be able to escape from
your heart
so it's better to listen to what it has
to say
when you want something all the universe
conspires in helping you to achieve it
it's the possibility of having a dream
come true that makes life interesting
when we love we always strive to become
better than we are
when we strive to become better than we
are
everything around us becomes better too
there is only one thing that makes a
dream impossible to achieve
the fear of failure
don't waste your time with explanations
people only hear what they want to hear
people are capable at any time in their
lives of doing what they dream of
you are what you believe yourself to be
anyone who loves in the expectation of
being loved in return
is wasting their time
life is too short or too long
for me to allow myself the luxury of
living it so badly
stay mad
but behave like normal people
run the risk of being different
but learn to do so without attracting
attention
if you start by promising what you don't
even have yet
you'll lose your desire to work towards
getting it
don't allow your mind to tell your heart
what to do
the Mind gives up easily
don't listen to the malicious comments
of those friends who
never taking any risks themselves
can only see other people's failures
when you can't go back
you have to worry only about the best
way of moving forward
you have two choices
to control your mind or to let your mind
control you
if you love someone
you must be prepared to set them free
to realize one's destiny
is a person's only obligation
we can never judge the lives of others
because each person knows only their own
pain
and renunciation
one has to understand that braveness is
not the absence of fear
but rather the strength to keep on going
forward despite the fear
we must never stop dreaming
dreams provide nourishment for the soul
just as a meal does for the body
[Music]
happiness is something that multiplies
when it is divided
be like the fountain that overflows
not like the cistern that nearly
contains
want to control someone
all you have to do is make them feel
afraid
a man must always hide three things from
a woman
is fears
so she believes in his strength
his mistakes so she believes in his
wisdom
and his dreams
so he can surprise her with their
realization
never trust a lonely friend because
while some find strength and solitude
Others May lose their way in it
what hurts us is what heals us
only two things can reveal life's great
secrets
suffering
and love
to conquer yourself
and you conquer the world
don't explain your friends do not need
it and your enemies will not believe you
you have to take risks
we will only understand the Miracle of
Life fully
when we allow the unexpected to happen
a life without cause is a life without
effect
you want to be successful you must
respect one rule
never lie to yourself
the two hardest tests on the spiritual
Road
are the patience to wait for the right
moment
and the courage not to be disappointed
with what we encounter
there is only one way to learn
it's through action
everything you need to know you have
learned through your journey
when each day is the same as the next
it's because people fail to recognize
the good things that happen in their
lives every day that the Sun rises
one day you will wake up and there won't
be any more time to do the things you've
always wanted
do it now